oh right the very interesting
discussions over on the David Pakman
show subreddit you can find it at david
pakman.com slash read it that's our EDD
IT more than nineteen thousand nine
hundred thousand of our viewers and
listeners are subscribed to the
subreddit a user Philo 19:27 posted
about the Trump administration's threats
to su states that don't lift pandemic
orders that's not going to go well and
we've been following that we've talked
about that a little bit on the bonus
show we've also talked about some of the
other funny business that's going on
related to states and stay at home
orders and what we are very quickly
seeing is that there have been
consortiums of reasonable states so
you've got one on the west coast we've
got one on the Northeast you've got some
others that are saying we don't really
care what Trump says we're going to do
what the public health experts in our
states determine we have to do that's
inspiring and so far it seems like the
threats from William bar Trump's Justice
Trump's AG in the Justice Department to
start suing States has had absolutely no
effect whatsoever Charlie Baker a
Republican here in Massachusetts
extended the stay at home an additional
two weeks from May 4th to May 18th I do
think we need to start figuring out by
mid to the end of May how to start
opening up elements of society both for
economic and mental health but it's got
to be done safely but there is no doubt
that we are not now ready to open and
I'm glad to see that most or many
governors are making the right decisions
despite Donald Trump's threats
intimidation and posturing that is
happening on a nearly daily basis that
is good news another post I spotted on
the subreddit is from mu tear boy who
says for those who think the virus might
sway at rumpus goes on to say I've seen
a few posts and had a few chats with
friends where people seem to think Trump
is going to be negatively affected by
things like recommendations of unproven
medications well not only is it not
going to affect his supporters I think
it will be worse than that as more and
more evidence comes to light about
potential harm caused by
hydroxychloroquine being inappropriate
being used inappropriately look for more
than a simple rat
Khanh of how it was presented by Trump
and Fox people are going to start
actively blaming doctors for having
actually prescribed them even if they
themselves requested it based on what
Trump said they will fall back on Trump
pointing out he's not a doctor and that
it should be up to doctors to not
prescribe or make available things like
this without evidence and what's worse
is that's probably fair if you ignore
the fact that America has a for-profit
medical system which pressures caught
doctors to do what their customers sorry
patients request rather than what's in
their best interest III don't have to
agree with everything that's said there
- generally concur and we had Rachel bid
a cougher political forecaster on the
program last week she doesn't think that
coronavirus by and large is going to be
the difference-maker in November in the
sense that Trump's handling of the virus
has been such that there are people
rallying behind him for his great job
those people were going to vote for him
anyway
the people that are rightly criticizing
the disastrous job he's done were likely
not going to vote for him anyway and in
particular the way the coronavirus will
affect the election is affecting turnout
if the virus is still spreading or again
spreading in wave - in the fall in
November that could hold down Democratic
turnout because Democrats are more
likely to pay attention to what public
health officials are saying than
Republicans if there is vote-by-mail
in November as a result of coronavirus
that'll be a decision made by individual
states that is more likely to boost
Democratic turnout relative to if it's
in-person voting during a pandemic so
the handling of the pandemic itself I
don't know that that is going to be a
difference maker in the fall in that
sense I agree indirectly how we vote in
the fall as a result of coronavirus may
well be the difference maker
particularly in those key swing states
everything from Ohio North Carolina
Michigan Wisconsin Pennsylvania etc one
other post I want to look at from the
David Pakman show subreddit reflex point
posted recent Fox News poll shows Biden
winning Florida by four points not too
recently it was a toss-up
sorry I meant plus three but Quinnipiac
shows him up for listen I want to be
very careful polls are important polls
or newsworthy it is our way to kind of
figure out where the wind is blowing but
I don't want any poll no matter how
lopsided one way or the other to prevent
someone from voting in November safely
vote by mail if that's what's determined
it has to be because you know we
actually have other put we Biden is up
one in a Texas poll now admittedly
that's a PPP poll those turn tend to
lean a little bit to the left Trump is
now up by I'm sorry Biden is now up by
several points in North Carolina there
are numbers coming out of Florida that
are really not good for Donald Trump it
would be a beautiful thing if Donald
Trump is absolutely crushed in November
it would be the right thing if Trump
were absolutely crushed in November I'm
not optimistic that that's when going to
happen I believe that if Biden wins it's
going to be close and Trump supporters
are going to say it was rigged and it's
going to be a real fight but there is no
question that there are polls right now
that should be red flags for Trump and
in fact we know that they are red flags
for Trump because he recently threatened
to sue his own campaign manager over the
fact that he's losing in a bunch of
polls and that's what we're going to
talk about next make sure you join the
discussion I want you participating in
these discussions on the david pakman
show subreddit find it at david
pakman.com slash re d di t